spider-man homecoming anybody see it  that was a good all right I took my son  and my daughter to see that was great  yeah that's a secure it opened this  weekend huge success massive success  many people were saying this is the  first movie to accurately portray  spider-man as a real awkward high school  teenager yeah now I saw I said I saw the  movie I took my kids we loved it I  thought this is my only criticism they  might have gone a little too far to  remind us that spider-man is still an  adolescent I think they overdid that  part a little bit take a look see what  you think what if somebody had died I'm  gonna need  oh my god  you  you